Speaker 1: It was not just a speech in North
Carolina that former President Donald Trump
gave this weekend.
Donald Trump, in his speech, made it clear
he's going to be the decider for Republicans
in twenty twenty two.
He will say who is OK to reelect or to vote
for and who is not?
Who is a Republican in name only or someone
who has abandoned the party as far as Trump
is concerned.
But Trump also recorded a Republican fundraising
video, and he is once again talking about
we're going to take back the White House sooner
than you think.
Now, I know that in the absence of any other
data points, hearing Trump say we're going
to take back the White House sooner than you
think, it might not have any real meaning.
That might not mean anything to us.
But when Trump says it, you have to understand
the context.
Trump is suggesting he will be back in the
White House before January of twenty twenty
five.
A normal person who hears a former president
say we will take back the White House.
That would mean to you at the next presidential
election, November of twenty twenty four.
But the addition of sooner than you think
means exactly what Donald Trump has been telling
people, according to both Maggie Haberman
from The New York Times and the right wing
National Review, which is he is going to be
back in power sooner than when he could be
by winning in November of twenty twenty four.
Here's the clip from this bizarre Trump fundraising
video.
Speaker 2: I want to thank everybody for the
tremendous support you've shown.
We're going to take back the Senate, take
back the House.
We're going to take back the White House.
And sooner than you think, it's going to be
really something special.
Speaker 1: But we're going to take back the
White House sooner than you think.
Trump is again, talking about somehow getting
Biden out before his term is up and getting
back in before Joe Biden's term is up.
Now, I really hope that people understand,
even if for any reason Joe Biden did not complete
his term, Kamala Harris becomes the president,
not Donald Trump.
They don't say, well, for some reason, Biden
is out.
Let's go back to the last guy or the one before
that or the one before that.
That's not how it works.
It goes to the vice president.
So aside from the ASP aspects of this that
relate to this being the same type of rhetoric,
again, that eventually led to the January
six riots, will discuss that more probably
tomorrow.
This is a complete fantasy world, understanding
or misunderstanding, better said of how our
government works.
The video was posted to the YouTube channel
of the National Republican Senatorial Committee.
The NRC, the Senate Republican fundraising
arm is what that is, and it was posted Friday.
It's not exactly clear when it was recorded,
but it shows Trump floating similar ideas
to what he's reportedly been saying in private,
that somehow this guy is going to be reinstated
as president.
Now, by itself, it might just sound like a
weirdly, weirdly phrased thing to say.
But then The New York Times, The Washington
Post, the National Review are all reporting
that Donald Trump believes this bizarre election
audit or audits that are going on are somehow
going to put him back in power at some point.
Isn't this seditious by Donald Trump?
Isn't this all pushing and pointing towards
rebellion against the established authority
of the United States, the current government?
Shouldn't someone go to the NSC or the North
Carolina Republican Party or whoever where
Trump has been saying this stuff and say what
exactly does sooner than you think mean?
Because that's really the question right now.
What do you believe, sir, is the soonest possible
date at which Donald Trump could again be
president?
If the answer is anything other than January
of 20 25, when the next president is inaugurated,
then, you know, you're dealing with a wacky
person.
And as these new Trump rallies start up again,
I would love to see this asked of the attendees.
People that are there, what do you think is
the soonest that Donald Trump could again
be president and if they say anything other
than January of twenty, twenty five, it will
give you a real sense of where the electorate
is at this point in time.
So a wacky, bizarre and deranged weekend.
And we're going to have more about the implications
of this a little bit later on in the program.
I will talk about Dr. Forces' emails.
I am going to talk about Joe Manchin.
It's a packed show.
I'm glad you're here.
And you can find me on Twitter for any story,
requests, commentary or trolling at Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
Remember that the David Pakman show is sponsored
primarily by viewers like you through the
David Pakman Show membership program, you
can grab a membership at Join Pakman Dotcom
coupon code available and never mandatory.
That code is better.
Twenty one, you'll get instant access to the
daily bonus show, the commercial free audio
and video streams of the show and so many
other great things.
And you'll be supporting the show.
That's that's the really key thing.
Sign up today at Join Pakman dot com.